I'm sorry I hadn't had the opportunity
of being involved with you in classes
prior to this time so it's hard for me
to think about the last lecture given to
my last lecture is the same as my first
lecture but that's an advantage
somesome doesn't allow it doesn't mean
necessitate that I tell you what we're
going to do as far as the assignments
and homework for the course you know I
hope this is the right room because
seeing so many of you reminds me of the
time when I had my mentor and great
colleague Merton Miller who we used to
teach in the downtown program at the
University of Chicago together and it
was a night program such as this a
little bit later than this so we used to
go for dinner prior to the actual
teaching experience and Merton always
used to have a martini before class to
quiet him down you didn't you might have
read a Merton Miller's work obviously in
your finance classes and this one night
for a particular reason at dinner he had
a second martini I was a little bit
worried about that but let it go and he
went to the classroom and then started
to write equations on the board and the
days in those days we did write
equations on the board
more so than now but base wrote
equations in the board and some of the
students said professor Miller said try
to get his attention he said wait till I
finish writing these down and we can
discuss them and then he wrote on the
second blackboard in the third
blackboard and the students were trying
to interject finally one student got his
attention and exasperation professor
Miller turned to them and said what is
it can't you see I'm trying to
articulate for you the theory and they
said professor Miller you're in the
wrong classroom
so we hope you're not in the wrong
classroom today today I'd like to talk
about liquidity and risk transfer chaos
and the role of hedge funds and I'll try
to tell you how all these are
interrelated and maybe it'll also for
you resurrect some of the memories from
your finance classes that you've had
here at the school but I'd like to first
of all talk about liquidity and risk
transfer which is an area that probably
we didn't focus that much on in the
finance classes and then relate that to
what I call chaos theory and then from
there we'll dabble in bring it back into
the hedge fund world and maybe into risk
management but I'll sort of bring this
up along the way when I when we think
about liquidity and worrying about
liquidity and risk transfer
I always think there are for past earn
returns for the provision of investment
services one way to do it and these all
relate to hedge funds are active
management is the ability to predict
systemic exposures and what I mean by
systemic exposures you might have
referred to that in class you know is
the market factor or the growth factor
or the value factor or the small stock
factor thee or these are systemic
exposures potentially additionally we
have systemic exposures which include
such things as you know the dollar
versus yen or the euro versus dollar
stocks versus bonds so this is a way if
one has skills in this dimension that
you can forecast these particular
factors then you can obviously make
money and
and we've done a lot of work in classes
saying you know it's hard for active
managers to do better than the market so
that led to the development of index
funds and index factors or
exchange-traded funds in which you can
buy the market without trying to
forecast
whether one exposure is better at the
moment than another exposure but
obviously there are macro hedge funds
and macro persons who actually spend
time trying to estimate systemic
exposures but basically we call we think
of this as a zero-sum game in that you
have to predict better than others
unless you have government's involved
and then the government set up the
opportunity for all of us to make money
such as when the Japanese government
wants to maintain the n low relative
that a dollar and won't let the N
appreciate it only does that for a
certain period of time before
speculators or can actually make money
so governments and macro policy also
enable us to make money on systemic
exposures one area second area is
probably you've all had professor
MacDonald's courses or courses such as
that which is the idea of prediction of
cash flows or present value analysis of
some form rather where we try to
forecast the underlying cash flows of
stocks and we discount those back to the
present maybe sometimes saying five
years from now the market can't be that
smart forecasting five years out so we
say we think of normal growth five years
hence but estimate what our growth will
be between now in five years from now
and say this stock is overvalued because
the market is forecasting too high a
cash flows whether it's the case the
market doesn't understand about the
quality of earnings or all the other
things we've learned we that allow us to
be able to predict cash flows but we
have to predict cash flows and discount
rates again better than others to make
money so that's a zero-sum game but it
has led that to the
tremendous growth in act of management
in the hedge fund industry which is the
long-short industry where managers are
forecasting cash flows at the same time
unlike mutual funds or institutional
investing the hedge fund person would
not only think their skills would result
in them being able to forecast stocks
that are undervalued but at the same
time being able to forecast those
thoughts that are overvalued so being
able to do both presumably allows the
one to have a long short strategy so
that you can isolate if you wish the
systemic exposures and concentrate a lot
of your activity more so in the things
you know unless so and the things you
don't know by hedging out systematic
exposures so your risk is lower by
hedging the systematic exposures you
increase your risk then by using
leverage bringing your risk back up
again
to that which might be the case if you
were long only but this way you're
concentrating on your expertise both of
those though again or zero-sum game in a
sense that you have you're superior than
someone else in the in the business the
third area in the fourth area which I'll
work more on because I don't know that
we've had much concentration on that in
the skin classes here and I've been
thinking about this recently is the area
of risk transfer and liquidity provision
now when I think of risk transfer what I
think of is in the way of the Keynesian
way of thinking about things
that's Maynard Keynes who studied in
your macro courses that basically
hedgers those who are hedging risks are
willing to pay speculators to carry
forward excess inventory into the market
place and basically we have had a change
over the last number of years to the use
of hedging
by corporations and by investors and
that growth of hedging in the futures
markets and in the over-the-counter
markets the goldman sachs is a Deutsche
Bank's the morgan stanley's etc a city
corbs
you have to realize that if we talk
about the trade-off in the efficiency of
capital between hedging and equity okay
that we've seen a growth in the use of
derivatives globally that means there's
a large hedging demands then at the same
time there has to be someone on the
other side of these contracts so not
everyone could want to receive in the
swap market while someone else has to be
on the other side and pay as a result of
the requirements of hedgers or the
desire for hedgers to hedge their risks
that means that we have to have
speculators wanting to come into the
market and provide these risk transfer
services now I think this area is not a
zero-sum game in the sense that the
hedgers know they're paying the
speculators to carry the risk forward
and additionally they would prefer
obviously to pay less but the more
speculators there are the lower the
spreads in the market place tend to be
and as a result that allows for more
hedging activity a standard example that
we give from the commodity market world
to illustrate risk transfer in its
simplest form is take the farmer who
grows wheat the week comes in at one
period of time it might come in the
united states to crops the winter crop
and the summer crop but those who store
the week are called Millers and the
Millers essentially buy the risks from
the farmer who sells the wheat to the
Miller the Miller stores
we'd so the inventory of risk is very
large because the wheat comes in at one
particular moment now interestingly
enough the Miller has two sources of
risk
one is the idiosyncratic risk the
idiosyncratic risk results from the
requirement of the Miller to hold the
wheat in storage and then mill the wheat
into flour as the Baker's come to buy
the flour from the Miller and then we as
consumers buy the bread and the cakes
okay
so the risk associated with the Miller's
idiosyncratic risk involved local
demands supply conditions in the
marketplace which cause there to be less
demand or more demand for cake and wheat
whether Atkins diet or some other
low-carb diet is in vogue
they might take risk associated with
selling that crop that we locally in
addition they always have the
operational risk of storage and the fact
that you know rats might eat into the
wheat or there's spoilage etc so that's
the idiosyncratic risk the other risk
though that the Miller has is the
general change in the price level of
wheat and the general price level of
wheat could be such that over the United
States at the wheat prices fall or
increase depending on the crop itself or
the general demand supply conditions in
the marketplace now the Miller can
retain both sources of risk the
generalized risk or the idiosyncratic
risk the Miller however to retain both
risks needs a tremendous amount of
equity to sustain themselves against
these risks but equity is expensive
because the equity in that case is only
needed sporadically once a year and then
is fallow for the rest of the year the
Miller then could hold both risks with
equity but the market allows the Miller
to
transfer the generalized risk to the
marketplace through the futures market
by transferring this risk the Miller has
what's called basis risk that's the
general change in the price of wheat
that's involved in futures contract and
the own specific or own wheat that is
being stored but the interesting issue
here is there's a trade-off between
equity and hedging and this is what's
permeating the Miller world it's also
permeating the corporate world and the
investment world the idea is how much
equity to have you need equity but it
caught the equity has a cost
there's a lot of deadweight cost to
equity and if you could reduce or
economize on the equity you need you
could reduce the cost of holding equity
relative to the cost of hedging and as
hedging increases or the requirement of
hedging knowledge about hedging and
skills increase where we hedge interest
rate risk we hedge bond risks we had
equity risks in the marketplace the
classic corporate and individual level
this creates a demand for speculators
without hedging you don't get
speculators you don't get risk transfer
and as a result of that we see a growth
in the provision of risk transfer
services from by using hedge funds or
the idea of hedge funds providing risk
transfer and the broker-dealer community
does it the Goldmans of City Corpse the
the JP Morgan's provide risk transfer
services as part of their business but
as the risks build up on their books
they would like to transfer the risks to
others in the marketplace because it's
just too much risk for them to take that
leaves a role for speculators that are
providing that through the hedge fund
world if you then say look at it from
the liquidity price definition okay that
we have under dem sets world which is an
article in 1968
liquidity is the price of immediacy
services the price of inventory risk for
carrying inventory risk for risk-averse
traders so is the risk of increases
volatility increases under this modeling
than traders would like to get a higher
rate of return to carry risks in the
marketplace so the price of and I want
to explain why the price of risk
transfer and liquidity changes in the
marketplace I distinguish liquidity from
risk transfer in the sense that we
always we think of risk transfer or
liquidity in the sense of thinking of it
as a spectrum of asset classes where we
think cash is the most liquid we think
we know you get a liquidity premium for
investing in low capitalized stocks you
know you get a liquidity premium for
convertible bonds less developed country
assets and we go to private equity world
the required rate of return on private
equity or restricted stock or venture
capital is much higher than that
required rate of return everything else
being equal for investing in IBM in this
liquidity spectrum we is the idea that
in a time of a crisis we would like to
liquidate in a time of a crisis you
can't if you're holding real estate it's
very hard to do or if you're holding a
liquid stock the cost of liquidation is
quite great on the other hand cash or
government bonds are most liquid I
distinguish between risk transfer and
liquidity because risk transfer is more
is by direction both sides in other
words that a man for hedging might be
such that a liquidity crisis risk
transfer could make money and acquit any
crisis it could lose money okay it
depends on what happens because we know
in a crisis liquidity crisis the
following things happen we know that
volatility increases in markets we know
that individuals prefer to go from the
long end of the carbon curve to the
short end we know that
spreads wide even though they're not
really credit spreads credit spreads
widen the market equity prices fall
volatility as I said goes up commodity
prices such as gold might go the
opposite way that's what we know in a
crisis the reverse happens when optimism
is in the marketplace so basically those
are the quiddity events the other hand
risk transfer requirements might be such
that the hedge fund or liquidity
provider happens to be long volatility
because a lot of people want to be
hedging by selling volatility in the
marketplace so they could be long
involved in the crisis make money and so
that's why I distinguish between
liquidity and risk transfer but the
interesting part is that the prices of
all this liquidity changes in the market
so when we did our analysis and looked
at portfolio theory and we looked at the
Sharpe models and Sharpe linear models
other models they were one period models
where we could sell everything at the
end of the period and reconstruct our
portfolios this is false as we know it's
a first approximation and we know in our
theory we have to bring in and our
thinking we have to bring in the idea
that we have the price of the quiddity
and the price of risk transfer are not
constant in the marketplace and all
these markets need risk transfer
services and pricing and I think that
the opportunity set is not constant in
the marketplace it changes over time and
the reason you need to have reason the
price liquidity and risk transfer
changes is because you need people you
need a team to analyze whether as a
speculator whether to provide liquidity
when to provide it and additionally the
same is true for risk transfer services
so the opportunity is not set is not
constant and the standard models do not
take account of changes in asset prices
because of liquidity and risk transfer
services the model of liquidity and risk
transfers
services that is necessary to make this
work is essentially it's it's sorry
about that let me see link it back here
it's necessary for all providers to have
a model of value of the underlying
security to be a speculator you need to
know model values so that's the first
step so you need technology to have a
model everyone needs a model to because
if someone says to me Myron I want you
to buy these suits these suits are cheap
you know they're very cheap you can make
money on it take this inventory today
speculate hold it for two or three
months and you'd be able to sell it out
that may be true but I don't know if
it's if I don't know if it's cheap or
not how do I know whether to buy this
suits and then liquidate them so
basically we need to have model risks we
need to estimate parameters and we have
to know whether the opportunity set is
changing okay because and those are
crucial so I think the other questions
we have to ask or why are there
deviations from the model why are market
participants willing to pay me to take
this risk off the person's hand in the
case of the Miller it becomes obvious to
the speculator because the Miller knows
that the real money is the real money
player or the inventory is accumulated
here and over here that we are going to
be buying that wheat and flour to bake
our cakes so that's the real money
players going to take it off as our
hands okay that's the process there's a
time between here at the time their
services are needed and over here when
the real money players are going to come
into the market and understand why
market participants are willing to pay
the flows that are necessary how long
will it take to carry the position and
how do you inform ultimate buyers that
they should take over the position for
you I mean Bill Gross at pemko is the
person who exemplifies this takes the
position goes on TV and says how stupid
we are not to own what he does so you
know it creates closure in the system so
and huh and then all
who will be the ultimate buyers I said
and how much capital is it necessary to
provide liquidity or risk transfer
services this depends on ability to
hedge factor exposures that we have how
much rate of return are we going to make
on our capital understanding who our
competition is and getting lines of
financing if we're going to be a levered
player in this in this particular
providing these particular services so
basically then the as I said the model
is there and then what we have in the
world is sort of a division of a need to
have an understanding of the market and
human capital we need teams of people in
a complex environment that we're in the
hedge fund or the persons in banks or
intermediaries providing services need
to have a human capital a team that can
able to answer these questions what's
the model what's the flows a combination
of modeling and qualitative analysis
Technic wont't ativ and qualitative
analysis are necessary to actually
undertake these businesses and do in a
profitable way have to have a contact
network have to understand things that's
one set of requirements and then at the
same time we need a longer horizon
players capital providers who can
provide capital to these teams to be
able to operate in the market place so
there we have high net worth investors
or pension funds endowments who have
long insurance companies have longer
horizons that can provide for this
capital and what we're trying to do is
in the world what we've seen over the
last 10 years or so is really a
separation of the human capital they're
teams from the capital providers or
holders and then figuring out ways to
marry them back together again so the
growth of hedge funds which I think have
a role in all four of the activities
that I described that's
systemic exposures analyzing cash flows
liquidity provision and risk transfer
activities really arisen to be able to
provide the human capital teams and then
raise money or figure out to raise money
from the capital sources to provide the
services that is are necessary from the
marketplace the survivorship in my view
those of the funds the ones that will
survive the longest and have a business
that's teachable and replicable and goes
over time are those businesses that are
involved in understanding the quiddity
provision and risk transfer that has in
my view the greatest survivor the
greater survivor rate so if we go now
and ask the question why do what do I
mean by chaos theory and how does it
relate to the changes in the price of
risk transfer services then it's let me
describe it this way what do I think of
as chaos we have a lot of random order
disordered events that occur to change
the nature of our process there are just
surprises that occur and basically we
know the following to be true that every
day we have earthquakes of one or two or
little surprises but over time we get
used to these earthquakes and we think
of these earthquakes as normal so we
call that evolution you know that's
normal
evolutionary processing you know so
that's the statistics we learn and we
think of this is normally distributed
accumulation of all these little shocks
but and time I think creates more
disorder in the way we think about
things and more more this need to
understand our models more things that
we thought we're for certain now tend to
become less so so there's more little
shocks that occur over time
and as we have more of this uncertainty
then what it does is tend to slow down
our decision-making time occasionally
what we would get is from time to time
we have important events occur which
might be classified as earthquakes of
four or five to seven whatever and we
notice that so time stops when we have a
very large stock and it really tries to
understand the implications of what we
have so we had a model or way of
thinking about venture capital
investment we had a model or way of
thinking about private equity or
investments in comms or whatever and
that model worked for a number of years
and then we had a shock say in 2000 and
we realized that there was something
potentially wrong with our models or how
we calibrated the models and as a result
of that time stopped what I meant was
decision time stuff it takes time to
understand models it takes time to
actually figure out what next to do and
so from that however it's not a closed
system because once we have a shock even
though some people might say venture
capital firms are like
deer-in-the-headlights you know they
don't not doing something they are doing
something they're thinking okay they're
trying to understand what's what's
happening and build new models and and
move forward that's where the value of
the human capital team comes in so
basically what we want to do is know
what information fits the purpose what
how we can solve our problem and you
know Einstein who was brilliant in his
way just like us in other ways but
everything he said should be made as
simple as possible but no simpler and
models assists our intuition help us
okay but we know they're wrong and say
in events or shocks will really change
what we have and then innovation really
arises by ascertaining what
information we should throw away how to
grow okay and as a result of that we end
up after the fact with what I call sir
the law of accelerating returns again
then as soon as we get excited about
things we learn things we get more
confidence we build a new model we get
new way of thinking about things then we
feed on the chaos around us and we have
gray growth again and value tends to
increase so we get a new venture capital
model is born or a new a private equity
world is born and we think of new ways
to make investments and we learn from
these shocks okay so innovation occurs
from chaotic events you know so I like
it to be the case and I was given an
opportunity I went to Milan to give a
talk a year or so ago and there was my
Caravaggio who's my most favorite artist
there was an exhibit in Bergamo which
was outside of Milan and I could decided
to rent a car and drive there myself
that there was a lot of chaos a lot of
noise I didn't know how to drive I
looked at the map so I decided to hire a
driver and the driver was amazing he
didn't have to even read the map you
know you knew the chaos was fog was not
there he was able to go directly to
where it was the exhibit got there and I
went there was a two-and-a-half-hour
line in the Sun and I was standing in
line and and I didn't know if I went on
my own whether I would even have gone or
stood in line and then the driver came
to me and he tapped me on the shoulder
and he said come on in and he directed
me to the VIP area and I went in there
and by the way there are some advantages
to being awarded a nobel prize in
economics and he left and i got in to
see the exhibit and I did saw it a
couple of times it was terrific he then
took me back to the car we went to a
wonderful place I had lunch there and
then went back to Milan so think about
the uncertainty reduction in so much
information around me and you figure out
what information to garner from that you
know just that it is an
amazing and that's the same thing that
happens that's what the value of the
human capital is that's the value of the
teams teams in place are able to analyze
more quickly and be able to figure out
how to innovate from chaotic shocks okay
there are many examples of shocks that
have really changed the financial system
and I'm not going to go through all
these in the time that I have but you
have the volatility the 70s cause
markets to collapse and liquidity prices
to change dramatically and and risk
transfer costs to increase innovation
occurred from these large salient events
and I won't the Euro caught in Europe in
Europe the markets actually caused
recession for many years while the
countries try to be able to get into the
euro and then after the euro was born
then you got new energy no new
innovation from that and a sense of more
pan urine is Bureau ISM and the like and
there's all these others that occur that
you can really delegate as earthquakes
of large magnitude where we can't say
they're just the normal process they
time stops and it really creates new
innovation and new structures so I think
that options are the key since I'm an
option person and we have to relate to
that that and I like that that options
are more valuable with increased
uncertainty so the more chaos that we
have the more uncertainty we have then
the greater the value of flexibility the
greater the value of flexibility but
it's more costly we have to trade-off
flexibility and cost if we have this
room we have a light switch which is
digital we have it on/off okay then it's
the case but that's the lowest cost
solution but it's not very flexible if
we want it to be flexible like having
the lights being able to dim the analog
system then essentially that has greater
cost so we're always trying to think
about the trade-off between between
flexibility the value of optionality
and our and our ability to to have cost
so reduce costs so basically in a
chaotic environment as we become more
global and I really believe that the
chaotic nature of our exists and the
number of shocks we will have of
magnitude four or greater will become
much larger over time than previously
and I think options are really the key
to that so in just summarizing here what
we have is that the process of all's we
have say in events which are mini shocks
and local shocks and global shocks that
affect us all and which will become more
prevalent and that tends to stop
investment so that we need were in
Silicon Valley right area and at
Stanford so we have to think about new
ways of thinking about things new mush
where then we need new software or
models and then new hardware so with
more uncertainty the value of teams you
construct and who you work with become
more important and more valuable in a
chaotic environment
so basically when a shock occurs the
capital market intermediaries the
Goldmans the city corpse the JPMorgan's
the odorous the hedge funds the
insurance companies and others withdraw
capital from the market and/or demand a
much higher price to provide liquidity
and risk services why do they do that
obviously you don't stand in the middle
of a freeway when a truck is coming at
you you don't know anymore whether your
models working you don't know anymore
whether your inputs are correct has
nature shifted from an urn which is here
to a new urn and how much do you wait
your old beliefs worse is in need for
new beliefs and new thinking so if say
in the events or shocks occur then the
price of liquidity and risk transfer
goes up people them intermediaries the
speculators withdraw capital until they
have time to recalibrate their model
but that's the huge value of having a
team in place does your team understand
more quickly than other teams if I say
the market collapse say in high-yield
and before March of 2003 and people said
Wow yield spreads are great what a great
investment without a team to analyze it
to have a model to understand the flows
to understand information how is it the
case one is going to enter and that
gives a huge advantage to teams in place
that are actually can analyze this but
it takes them time and prices will widen
dramatically in the market just at the
same time when de manors of liquidity
and risk transfer are willing to pay
much more to hedge the prices of options
skyrocket in the market at that time and
you also see this reflected in common
stock prices and you can define the
quiddity factors where the price of
small stocks for example go up and go
down dramatically relative to large
thoughts at times in which volatility
spikes up or shocks occur and and the
demanders are willing to pay more and so
additionally governments tend to act to
impede the adjustment process in the
market and this creates this creates the
idea that it's too smooth at times mr.
greenspan and others try to smooth out
uncertainty and at times a shock occurs
like we have Yellowstone Park where we
had there that putting out fires every
period of time cause because save the
environment but and then fires were put
out however when a huge combination or
convolution of shock occurred and a
lightening occurred across the park
there was myriad fires and that caused
huge damage in the park so sometime we
don't know the right amount of ball to
that we don't know the right amount of
chaos to have but trying to dampen all
chaos could lead to huge shock so
occurring in the
if if we intervene and as a result of
that the price of liquidity and risk
transfer could change dramatically but I
think after though then grow after the
shocks occur we get new innovation and
new growth occurring and new and new
value added so to just summarize here is
that when we have we think of liquidity
and risk transfer and hedge funds the
hedge funds are essentially in my view
providing an economic service in that
they are willing to step in and provide
specula services whether it's in the
fixed income markets or the equity
markets and the value of our human
capital is ever increasing or teams that
we establish and the reason I say teams
is because of the necessity for more of
us to get together and think about the
problem than we can do alone I always
have felt that the Turing test which is
about touring deciding of whether a
computer is an artificially intelligent
versus a man as you put the computer and
a man behind the screen and then experts
ask them questions and if the experts
can't distinguish then we know the
machine is artificially intelligent but
why would be so stupid to put a man
against the machine we put men and women
against the Machine and the men and
women against the machine probably could
completely beat it because we can create
teams that will be able to do that so I
think the future is very exciting for
finance and and what I have done over
the last year is getting more and more
excited about new models new ways of
thinking about things in technology that
we can put into place so I've now had my
nutritionists I'm trying to preserve my
life I have my Pilates instructor and I
diet and exercise and the like and to be
here some I hope I can give my last
lecture 40 years from now and hope it
will be my last lecture thank you very
much and
well that's an empirical question
obviously but a lot of the risk that to
be a company you have to bear
idiosyncratic risk you can't make money
unless you bear it is incredibly that's
how the company makes money but on the
other hand when I when I first started
in the business there was no way that at
Goldman Sachs or JP Morgan or any of the
banks for example knew how they were
making money they didn't know whether
they're making money because the price
of inventory was changing or they're
making money because they were turning
over the inventory businesses make money
by turning over inventory not by taking
inventory risks okay that's not their
expertise so basically what we'd expect
to happen is the idiosyncratic risk is
retained by the corporation and then all
the generalized risks are thrown away
and what we're just going to see in the
future is a huge separation of
businesses so risk will be transferred
from corporations those risks that they
have no competitive advantage in and
retain those risks that they have a
competitive advantage right now the
equity is a cushion okay against all
risks and we're fit and that equity
cushion is expensive because the market
doesn't know if you combine all risks
into the same basket
what risk you have expertise and what
risks you don't have expertise and
taking and it's difficult to measure or
judge how the company is making money
because of skill luck etc because of the
whole bundle of risks they're taking my
view and this is a trade off and I
didn't say I know the answer we have
risk transfer and hedging which is
costly competes against equity
that's also costly and so we have to
think of those trade-offs I know in the
last number of years we've seen the
growth - hedging and the growth and
hedging maybe it'll revert maybe it'll
go back or maybe we'll think that
neither model works don't forget
equities a young model equities only
been in existence say since 19 since
1900 or so and it's a very young model
and it has great number of flaws you
know risk transfer in some of the things
you're referring to have flaws as well
but we'll have to see if that lets let's
see the competitive act will be
competitive a clear room will be
survivorship which will survive which
will evolve and the new infrastructures
that are being put into place are trying
to service this transfer yes well my
thoughts are that an option should be
valued as a part of a compensation I
second is that I believe that the
arguments are wrong that say that you
cannot use options to value long dated
contracts we see that every day if you
go to Deutsche Bank or or know Maura you
know there are have very long data
contracts plus the hedge funds
themselves are buying very long dated
options so the argument is specious
which say that if the stock goes down
how could we have had the right value
for the option the same way if the stock
goes up so but that's confusing the
valuation of what I give you from the
return on what I give you if I give you
stock okay
$100 or the stock and it goes to 200
what I give you I gave you a hundred
dollars where the stock not 200 and vice
versa if it goes from one
two-fifty so you have to distinguish
those two things and I think that
argument is wrong if we have actually
fair value if I go to options exchange
and I buy an option and the stock goes
up the question is not whether the
option price that's not a way to judge
whether the option price is wrong or
right okay but I think that we have an
the argument of the debate should be
what is the nature of the contract
underlying the executive option grant
and there the issue might be like bülow
and Chauvin have this argument that it's
really only a 90 day contract and their
simple idea there is that if you fire an
executive that executive has to exercise
her option within 90 days and if the or
if the person leaves the firm or you
know cetera so it's a renewal of options
over 90-day periods
that's an explicit contract versus an
implicit contract which says I'm gonna
work for the firm for 10 years so I
think that the really interesting debate
and this is something that obviously is
idiosyncratic to particular corporations
is what is the nature of the contract
you know the best thing what is the
nature of leaving etc but I think that
basically they are an expense of the
corporation and that they should be
caught that as part of compensation it
should be deducted yes one more make
sure that we select and wow there's that
question I can give my last lecture in
another last lecture in that because one
of the interesting parts about running a
business which I've done I have a hedge
fund that I'm sort of the leader of with
my other people and I've had to think
about leadership okay and what that is
are running a firm and it's a
combination of leading or thinking about
how you can direct people to satisfy the
objectives that you want
but it's also appreciation in other
words I think that it's necessary to be
able to have a business that is so I say
80% science and 20% intuition because if
I can't that we can't figure out a way
to direct someone or train someone to do
something then that's it can't be sort
of a leader of the team or build a team
that's going to work second is that you
have to be able to appreciate someone
and what they have done so you know it's
like in the Army they call it command
and control or whatever but basically
that ingredients of lead of building
these teams ok as being able to specify
objectives clearly be able to set up
ways in which you have synergistic
effects being able to talk with each
other and make sure you got cross
fertilization of ideas I separate our
traders from the strategist I don't
trade myself and I'm you know chief
strategist or semi chief strategy joint
chief strategist
they people who gather information and
make the hypotheses and the think about
things should be separate from the group
that actually makes the decision about
capital allocation simply because I
think that person's gathering data can
be too much in the trees great teams can
figure out how to be in the trees and
then look at the forest and figure out
how to when to do both and and I know in
my organization we are not strong enough
or I'm not strong enough to do both
simultaneously so I try to separate that
functionality I think the idea of
mimicking is important for team we're
taught and school not to copy not the
steel that's baloney out there you steal
everything you can you know mimic
reverse-engineer the best thing you can
and I and we try to learn from everyone
else you know that's what a team is to
do and how to do that as opposed to
reinventing the wheel
that's crucial I think also framing
problems that you should work on they're
crucial the idea of you know if you go
home at night you go to sleep you're
working on the wrong problem that's
silly why not work on the right problem
so the executive who walks around
and has his team and says boy I'd like
to you know I think pheasants are
wonderful fine I wish I knew where
pheasant farms are all up you rush off
and figure out where pheasant farms are
that's not the right problem and
objective additionally I think when a
team to make a team work you have to
cross-train
the most important thing is to try to I
in my office I have flowers I have
paintings I have we have seminars where
we go to everyone in the groups can go
to different seminars so this frees the
mind up for creativity and being able to
make the team richer additionally I
think having truth and Trust is
important so when you tell the truth and
you have constructive criticism the team
is richer than if you don't have this
truthful and trusting way of interacting
and that's important in how you build it
so you have to have a feedback system
you have to keep learning you have to be
honest and if you're not honest through
feedback you don't get this appreciation
you don't get the right results and the
last point that I think is so important
is persistence don't change objectives
willy-nilly all the time stay -
discipline because energy is dissipated
the only in our business you have flows
the energy comes and you make money and
if you dissipate that energy getting too
much entropy in the system then it's
hard to restart takes time to restart
again so you have to make sure that you
keep your energy level up and you keep
your objectives and you're set on your
objectives and and you don't lose those
objectives and how you're thinking of
things so that's it I got to get off
here if they'll throw me out of here